Vamos a hacer un problema de
calentamiento de razones
para que después podamos
resolver otros más difíciles.
Supongamos que tenemos que 13 entre 6,
la razón 13 entre 6,
es igual a la razón 5 entre "x"
y que queremos determinar el valor de "x".
Bueno, aquí la "x" está en el denominador
y eso no nos gusta porque la hace difícil
algebraicamente,
así que vamos a hacer que quede en el numerador, multiplicando ambos lados de la igualdad por "x",
multiplicamos por "x" aquí , multiplicamos por "x" acá,
de este lado esta "x" se cancela con esta "x"
y nos queda que 13 entre 6 por "x"...
13 entre 6 por "x" es igual a 5 ...
a 5, sale.
Bueno, después de esto podemos
multiplicar por el inverso de 13/6
en ambos lados de la igualdad, es decir,
multiplicamos por 6 entre 13...
por 6 entre 13 y con esto vamos a despejar "x"
porque de este lado estos términos se cancelan,
justo eso era el punto de multiplicar por el inverso y de este lado nos queda 6 por 5 que es 30 entre 13,
de esta forma "x"
es igual a 30...
a 30 entre 13.
Muy bien, bueno, puede ser que algunas veces
veas que unas personas hagan algo que se llama
multiplicar cruzado, ¿eso que quiere decir?
Quiere decir multiplicar el numerador de este lado
por el denominador de este lado
e igualarlo al numerador de este lado multiplicado
por el denominador de este lado.
Vamos a hacerlo para que veas a lo que me refiero,
o sea, voy a volver a copiar el problema,
decía que 13 entre 6 es igual a 5 entre "x",
entonces estas personas dicen,
Hay que multiplicar 13 por "x",
lo ponemos de un lado y eso es igual a 5 por 6
y lo ponemos del otro y ya, de aquí esta igualdad.
Esto de aquí pues parece magia, verdad,
porque parece un mecanismo que tenemos que hacer,
pero no sabemos porque, porque funciona y bueno
y la razón por la cual funciona es muy sencillo,
simplemente hay un paso intermedio
que es multiplicar por ambos denominadores
de ambos lados de la igualdad, es decir, lo
que estamos haciendo en el fondo es multiplicar
aquí por "6x", o sea la multiplicación de
este 6 con esta "x"
y de este lado también por "6x", sale,
¿y qué sucede?
Este 6 se cancela con este 6,
esta "x" con esta "x"
y justo queda que 13 por "x" es igual
a 5 por 6, que es igual a 30, vale,
y bueno a partir de aquí podemos despejar "x" multiplicando por 1 entre 13
ó bueno dividiendo entre 13,
dividimos entre 13 acá y acá,
aquí se cancelan y justo nos queda
que "x" es igual a 30 entre 13 otra vez.
Muy bien, entonces este fue
el problema de calentamiento,
vamos a resolver algunos problemas
un poco más difíciles.
Mira, tengo este problema de aquí
que dice lo siguiente.
Dice, la montaña más alta de Canadá
es el Monte Logan,
es de 298 entre 67 la altura del Ben Nevis, otro monte, de hecho dice que es el pico más alto de Escocia.
Bueno vamos a ir pasando la información vale,
entonces dice,
el Monte Logan es de 298 entre 67
la altura del Ben Nevis, déjame usar la
letra "l" para Logan y esto es igual a 298
entre 67 la del Ben Nevis,
le voy a poner "n" para Ben Nevis, vale.
Bueno, luego nos dicen...
nos dicen, el Monte Elbert en Colorado
es el pico más alto de las Montañas Rocosas,
muy interesante...
Y luego dice, el Monte Elbert...
el Monte Elbert tienen 220/67 la altura del Ben Nevis,
vamos a copiar eso, eso se ve importante,
lo voy a poner "e" para Elbert, esto es 220...
220 entre 67...
entre 67...
la del Ben Nevis que le puse "n"...
"n"
y además también nos dicen que 44 entre 48 la altura del Mont Blanc, el Monta Blanc que está en Francia,
vamos a ponerle "b" para Mont Blanc.
Entonces él mismo,
el Monte Elbert tiene 44 entre 48...
44 entre 48, la altura del Mont Blanc,
lo voy a poner así, "b" y finalmente nos dicen
que el Mont Blanc tiene 4800 metros de altura...
vaya, al fin aparece una medida verdad,
entonces nos dicen que el Mont...
nos dicen que el Mont Blanc,
tiene 4800 metros de altura, va.
Y la pregunta que nos hacen es,
¿cuál es la altura del Monte Logan?
Bueno, aquí tenemos un montón de igualdades,
entonces vamos a ir encontrando el valor de
cada una de las letras vale,
como tenemos la "b"...
la "b" de burro, entonces sería bueno determinar
la "e", porque podemos utilizar esta igualdad,
entonces déjame sustituir en vez de "b" su valor,
entonces reescribiendo esta igualdad
nos queda que "e" es igual a 44 entre 48,
multiplicado por 4800...
4800 y entonces de aquí nos da el valor de "e".
"e" nos queda igual a...
a ver 4800 entre 48 es 100,
entonces esto es 100...
Y luego 100 por 44 es 4400,
entonces "e" nos queda igual a 4400 metros, vale.
El monte Elbert mide 4400 metros,
bueno, ahora esta información
vamos a pasarla para acá,
entonces tenemos que 4400 metros...
4400 metros,
es igual.. es igual a 220 entre 67...
220 entre 67, por "n" la del Ben Nevis, entonces
entonces le voy a poner por "n".
Ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es despejar esta "n",
¿cómo le hacemos?
Multiplicamos por el inverso de 220 entre 67
de ambos lados de la igualdad, o sea multiplicamos
por aquí por 67 y dividimos entre 220
y también hacemos lo mismo de este lado,
por 67 y dividimos entre 220.
Muy bien, del lado derecho se cancelan,
ese era el punto, voy a voltear la igualdad,
entonces nos queda que "n"...
que "n" la altura del Ben Nevis
es igual a 67 por 4400 entre 220.
Muy bien, vamos a ver qué podemos hacer aquí...
aquí me falto un 0, 4400...
a ver, 440, así sin este 0 entre 220 es 2,
si cabe justo 2 veces 220 en 440,
pero además tenemos este 0,
entonces haciendo esta división
nos queda 20, va,
entonces la altura del Ben Nevis
es igual a 67 por 20 metros.
Y eso podríamos desarrollarlo, 2 por 7 es
14, llevamos 1, 2 por 6 es 12, es como 1340, creo...
pero bueno, lo voy a dejar expresado así porque al parecer va a ser útil ese 67 de este lado.
Ahorita vas a ver a lo que me refiero.
Entonces finalmente sustituimos para obtener
la del Monte Logan y nos queda que la altura
del Monte Logan, es igual a 298 entre 67,
multiplicada por la altura del Ben Nevis,
que es 67...
67 por 20,
entonces observa,
justo aquí está bueno tener el 67
para que se cancele con este de acá
y finalmente nos queda qu
e la altura del Monte Logan...
del Monte Logan es is igual a...
a ver, 298 es casi 300, 2 por 300 es 600,
pero faltaban 2 para 300, entonces ahora deben
de faltar 4 para 600, o sea, 2 por 298 es 596,
pero ademas aquí hay un 0,
entonces aquí le tengo que poner 0,
entonces la altura del Monte Logan,
es de 5960 metros.
Muy bien, entonces ya tenemos la altura
del Monte Logan, sale
Vamos a resolver un problema de aquí abajo,
un problema adicional, vale.
Nos dice lo siguiente,
dice,
en una preparatoria grande,  se estima que dos de cada tres estudiantes tienen un celular,
y uno de cada cinco tiene un celular
que tiene menos de un año,
vamos a pasar esta información,
le voy a hacer así, le voy a llamar a "x"...
o más bien,
voy a llamar "x" al número total de estudiantes...
al número de estudiantes...
estudiantes
de la escuela, vale....
estudiantes...
Muy bien, entonces nos dicen que 2 de cada
3 estudiantes tienen un celular...
voy a poner en color azul...
entonces 2 de cada 3 tienen un celular,
esto se escribe como que 2/3 de "x" es el
número de estudiantes con celular...
lo voy a poner...
estudiantes...
estudiantes con celular...
con celular, vale.
Y además nos dicen que 1 de cada 5...
que 1 de cada 5 tiene un celular que tiene
menos de 1 año, entonces 1/5 de "x" es igual
a al número de estudiantes...
de estudiantes...
estudiantes con celular...
celular...
¿qué dice?
que tiene menos de 1 año...
voy a poner así, menos de 1 año.
Muy bien, y luego nos dicen,
de entre los estudiantes que tienen celular,
¿qué proporción tiene un celular
que tiene más de un año?
Bueno, entonces tenemos que sacar una proporción,
pero lo que nos interesa como denominador
es los estudiantes que tienen celular.
Entonces déjame ponerlos, lo estudiantes
que tienen celular, los voy a poner por acá,
o sea, la proporción
que nos interesa determinar,
debe de tener en el denominador
los estudiantes que tienen celular,
o sea 2/3 de "x"...
2/3 de "x".
Y de ahí nos preguntan,
¿qué proporción tiene un celular
que tiene más de 1 año?
Aquí nos dan el número de estudiantes con
celular de menos de 1 año,
entonces tenemos que ahora encontrar
la cantidad de estudiantes que tienen,
pues un celular con más de 1 año.
Entonces a los que tienen celular, les debemos restar los que tienen un celular con menos de 1 año,
vale, entonces voy a ponerle por aquí...
2/3 de "x" menos 1/5 de "x"
y justo esto es el número de estudiantes...
nada más le voy a poner así, est., con celular...
con celular de más de 1 año, vale.
Bueno, por ahí están los que tienen exactamente 1 año, vamos a pensar que están aquí abajo, vale.
Va entonces, número de estudiantes con
celular de 1 año o más,
entonces vamos a realizar esta resta
para encontrar cual es la proporción,
debemos de pasar estas fracciones
a su denominador común,
déjame factorizar la "x",
la voy a poner acá
y entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es, pues el denominador común es 15,
2/3 es lo mismo que 10 entre 15
y a eso tenemos que restar 1/5
y eso es lo mismo que 3 entre 15, vale,
y aquí es 10 menos 3 es 7,
entonces esto es igual a 7,
7 sobre 15 por "x".
Entonces esto de acá es el número de estudiantes
con celular de más de 1 año,
eso lo tenemos que poner en el numerador de esta fracción, aquí ponemos 7 entre 15 por "x", vale.
Entonces aquí está el número de estudiantes
con celular de más de un año
y el número de estudiantes con celular.
Muy bien,
vamos a ver cuanto nos da esta proporción.
La "x" se cancela con la "x",
eso es bueno porque queremos un número al final
y esto nos queda...
a ver es, 7 entre 15...
7 entre 15 y tenemos que dividir
entre esta fracción,
lo cual es lo mismo que multiplicar por su inverso,
por 3/2...
por 3/2, muy bien,
este 3 con este 15 se hace 1/5,
aquí se hace un 1, dividimos entre 3
arriba y abajo y de esta forma
la proporción nos queda 7 entre 10,
vale, 7 entre 10.
Y entonces 7 entre 10,
justo es la proporción de estudiantes
que tienen un celular con más de un año
entre aquellos que tienen celular.
Y listo, con esto terminamos.